moi j'ai senti dès le début que mon
discours était en phase avec celui des
militants pourquoi parce qu'il était
sincère il était vrai c'est ce que je
crois c'est ce que je pense c'est ce que
j'ai toujours pensé j'ai toujours été
dans ma famille politique les soirs de
victoire c'est facile tout le monde est
là tout le monde court les soirs de
défaite il y en a beaucoup qui s'échappe
au risque de l'élongation pour courir
plus vite on a vu au moment de
l'élection de macron tous ceux qui nous
ont quittés tous ceux qui ont quitté
françois fillon moi j'ai vu des amis où
on va dire des anciens amis pour rire
mais alors avec une force derrière
françois fillon pour essayer de
d'aspirer une petite place de est arrivé
de partir mais vers macro avec la même
célérité c'est grâce à la politique donc
mais moi je jeune homme de fidélité de
vérité on aime ou on n'aime pas mais
j'ai toujours dit la même chose j'y
crois profondément et le problème de la
politique c'est l'insincérité c'est
quand tu tiens on quand on tient un
discours qui est contraire à ce qu'on
pense moi toutes les idées sont
respectables seul de l'extrême gauche
celle d'autres pour autant qu'on y croit
et qu'on ait des idées et pour moi le
maquereau nîmes c'est l'absence d'idées
le en même temps c'est quand on pense
tous en même temps passe plus rien voilà
moi je préfère que ce soit tranchée qui
est des idées qui est des choix qui est
des débats et je suis dans ces débats
alors mes idées elles sont souvent
contestées mais en tout cas elles sont
sincères comme
j'avais déjà
dit ça se passe avec valérie pécresse
très bien j'ai vu que le dernier sondage
incroyable valérie pécresse sera au
deuxième tour et elle battrait le
président sortant est ce que ça sera la
première femme président de la
république est convaincu ou pas penser
qu'il va gagner elle va gagner alors
prêt ça sera génial pour notre pays un
gage un signe de mordelles de modernité
extraordinaire la première femme
président de la république comme c'est
formidable s'est déjà rien que ça
c'est c'est un signe fort en ce moment
oui j'y crois parce que la salle a lâché
parce qu'à un moment on a senti un petit
après le après l'élection de valérie
pécresse on a senti
un homme qui voit là un petit grain de
sa non est-ce que ça y est maintenant
réglé les choses sont claires moi je
suis persuadé que cette élection elle va
se gagner à droite parce que c'est quoi
la droite la droite c'est aimer la
france c'est mon cas et met son histoire
ne pas la renier ses croire à l'autorité
pour qu' il y ait l'ordre par tous et
qui est plus des gens qui fasse régner
l'ordre de la violence dans les
quartiers c'est croire cette fière de
notre histoire on vient pas de nulle
part j'ai pas envie qu'on vienne nous
imposer d'ailleurs d'autres modes de vie
etc enfin pouvoir travailler tranquille
sans être accablé d'impôts aujourd'hui
les français ils tiennent on gagne
chaque année la coupe du monde des
impôts c'est plus possible d'en quête de
droite c'est moi off c'est la france
c'est la sécurité c'est moins
d'immigration et c'est moins d'impôts
vous alors vous apprenez d'accord là
dessus si elle est présidente elle vous
a déjà annoncés pratiquement au ministre
de l'intérieur se joue pas comme ça je
crois que c'est pas maintenant qu'on
répare foire il est vrai que ces voix là
elle a eu l a dit vous étiez le nouveau
chef charles pasqua fait un compliment
alors alors voilà donc c'est ce qu'elle
a dit donc c'est vrai que voilà tout le
monde vous voit en nouveau miné de
l'intérieur si valérie pécresse est élu